Hello Freak bitches,
and I thought I had lost that and I,
I was at a point in my life where,
like I said,
I was where I wanted to be doing what I was wanting to do.
I thought I was doing it right and I mean it.
I thought I was going to die in 36 hours after getting shot.
I got off the stairs of an airplane in Virginia beach and my wife had my son in
a stroller and was pregnant with my second,
my middle son.
It just was such a bizarre series of events that happened so quickly and I went
from going so fast to nowhere,
to having nothing to do,
to not understanding why I couldn't train my body to get back to where I was
because the only job I'd had in my adult life other than working for my father,
I had too much.
I had too much invested in that occupational title and I think one of the best
things that I was able to do in my military career was to survive it and get out
and to move on.
That's one of the hardest things for fighters as well.
It's a big thing with them and may fighters boxers too.
They just don't know what to do when it's over.
They have.
They become these incredible winners in this one avenue and then once that's
done,
they rarely achieved that same kind of success in anything else where they're
probably not thinking about anything else.
When in the middle of fighting,
which is very common with people in the military too,
because the job does require a very focused,
myopic sense of drive.
This is what you need to do,
especially in the seal teams.
It's the team comes first,
team gear,
personal gear.
Then take care of yourself,
worried more about the person to your left into the right and then worry about
yourself,
you know,
consider the impacts of your actions and your words on the people around you and
then on yourself.
So it's very.
It is very driven down into a laser like focused,
but that's also required to survive and thrive in those environments.
But if left unchecked,
you'll end up at the end of your career not prepared for the next phase of your
life and say you do 20 years in the military,
which is what you need to do to get to retirement.
You joined when you're 18,
so hey,
you're 38.
Well the average lifespan of American is what?
80,
85.
You got a lot of time left.
What do you do?
And if you haven't thought about it,
it's,
it's it.
As see guys who struggle.
I see guys and I struggled myself,
but I think I,
I think I went through that struggle while I was still in and I think that
struggle allow me to lift my chin up just a little bit to look around and start
thinking about the future.
You know,
there's a lot of shows that turns out like,
Whoa,
this is a four seasons of this that you never heard of it.
Like maybe it's just me,
maybe I'm that.
And it's totally possible because there's always some fucking new musical
artists and like,
well who the fuck is that?
And I'll go to their instagram page.
They have 14 million followers and I'm like,
oh,
it's me.
I'm that old man.
I'm that old banner.
Doesn't know Jack Shit.
Uber coming here was this old prolly Armenian guy,
probably sixties racist.
Triggered a,
stopped the show.
He,
uh,
he's listening to what I assume he thinks people want to listen and it's all
this
shit.
I couldn't name you a fucking Jay z from a,
that kind of shit.
I don't know any of it.
And I'm about to say,
hey,
you don't have to play this for us.
But then I saw him lip sinking to the lyrics and tapping his fingers.
Oh,
on the steering wheel.
I'm like,
wow,
how out of the loop in my,
if fucking 60 year old for an uber and Uber drivers know all the words to these
fucking songs.
But you never been a music guy.
No.
No music.
Now that's something that not possible.
I mean,
I have songs I like can we will.
What's a great song like Doug Stanhope?
Here's your.
Oh yeah.
Sits back.
Most of the new songs that I've,
I've learned I've either heard playing in a store or on a commercial and I go,
ah,
that's catchy.
Do live chat,
chat,
chat.
Don't you know that?
I love you.
Ciao.
Bye.
Jimmy luxury.
Yeah,
it's from like 1997.
It was on the soundtrack of a movie go and then they disappeared.
You can't even find where the band is now,
but it was on a corona commercial.
I love it and I use it as intro music all the time.
That pumps me up.
They go sing a song.
Well,
give me some volume.
See,
I'm just seeing the video on
mute.
I'm into their song.
This is great.
Headphones.
No,
just know that I love you.
Always.
They.
I like how these gals are dressed like they're 19 fifties.
Cover girls.
What is it about that look
right?
That like cover pinup girl.
That's what it's called.
Nineteen fifties.
Pinup girl type of look.
What is it about that feeling appealing?
Maybe it makes fat chicks look good.
Dare you doug.
Stan hope.
Do you not realize it was a different day and age?
You can't say that anymore.
Those days are done.
What's wrong with a fat girl looking good?
What's wrong with you?
You wait.
It was,
it's a great thing.
And it still is.
I,
you know,
I still write songs for people.
I still write with people when they asked me to do that for because it's cool to
get into somebody else's head or a kind of sit down with them and,
and try to help them realize some vision of what it is they want to do.
And that's still one of my favorite things to do and I,
I'm just as interested in that as I am and,
and doing my own thing.
Wow.
So when you learn how to write music,
um,
did you,
when you would write what you,
do you sit down with an idea in mind with a guitar?
Do you sit down with a pen and pad?
Like how do you,
how do you write songs?
Well,
if I'm riding by myself or with somebody because there's a lot of different
processes,
it can be,
you know,
whatever comes up that day for me.
Generally if I just going to say,
Hey,
I'm going to sit down and go over in that corner and write a song,
I'd have a guitar,
I'd probably have a legal pad and a pen much likely have sitting right here and
I'd start strumming until that felt like something and how does that make me
feel?
I don't know.
Keep started humming the melody maybe and hopefully somewhere in humming.
The melody of word would pop out that are noise I would make,
would turn into a word and from there you can kinda grow this thing into
whatever it is supposed to be.
Now that that's how I would do it if I was sitting around by myself.
Now there's other times you and I could be having a conversation and you could
say a phrase or a line or or I could read a sign going down the road.
If you're a songwriter,
you're always writing songs.
It's not like a choice that you have.
It's like a,
an affliction that you have in some way,
so you just kind of walking around a unconsciously things will hit you,
you know,
and,
or moments will hit you or visual.
We're hit you and that will spark something.
So that's,
that's really,
um,
it can come from anywhere and that's.
And that's the truth.
Here's the problem with Western medicine,
you know,
we're facing this.
I mean,
it's like a war against chronic disease.
It's like we're being invaded by,
you know,
remember Independence Day with all this,
in doctors,
we got bb guns.
I mean,
that's the stuff we are shooting at them.
Doesn't work for chronic disease now.
Acute stuff,
it's different,
you know,
there's some stuff that we have this wonderful technology,
but the road in the middle of diabetes and obesity doctors are great for fixing
broken jaw joint.
Broke his phone.
Yeah.
There's no doubt about that.
Even even like arthritis that I sell every day,
you know,
if we were trained properly in nutrition and exercise,
that's what I've done my whole life.
I know what I'm doing exercise wise.
But you know,
if we were allowed to do that and instead of training all these,
you know,
radiology technicians and blood draw technicians and nursing assistance,
if you had an army of preventive medicine people and then we train all these
people to go into people's homes,
you know,
I think Chris was talking about that and just get the crap out of their diet and
show them how to be healthier.
You know what I mean?
You would,
you'd save,
you know,
it's funny watching the politicians debate about healthcare,
how to fund it,
you know,
it's like you guys are arguing about the titanic as it's coming up into the
iceberg and you're done.
You're arguing about the color of the deck chairs.
I mean,
we're going over a cliff and we're not fixing it by keeping,
putting bandaids.
You're not gonna write you.
The technology's not going to fix diabetes.
Nutritionist,
you know,
that you're essentially dealing with the problem when it's already gotten to a
point where you're in the hospital.
Yeah,
I mean there's,
you know,
like I said,
there's a guy,
Peter Attia,
I don't know if you know,
he is,
but he,
he talks about when he was a surgeon,
he felt like he was at the bottom of a building and somebody is throwing off and
his job is to catch the eggs are gone,
right?
And he's like,
well,
why don't we just have a guy stopped fucking thrown out?
And that's what medicine is.
You're just catching the eggs.
And so instead of that,
we should be investing,
you know,
all we talk about prevention,
but it's bullshit.
We don't do anything for prevention.
It's so little and it'll little problem.
The problem is a lot of it is it doesn't work the way we've designed it,
you know.